ah j'ai pas misogyne même pression je la
vois bien mais ailleurs
je vois bien chez elle en train de faire
le ménage ou s'occuper de ses enfants
voilà
[Musique]
je chercherai avec vous les majorités
les plus larges
sans que personne
est à renoncer à ce qu'il est là
vraiment on est dans un système
incroyablement monarchique regardez le
parcours de Madame de Pompadour regardez
le parcours d'Édith Cresson il y a un
parallélisme certain j'ai entendu des
députés derrière moi
elle est pas mal foutue
ah j'ai pas misogyne même façon je la
vois bien mais ailleurs
je vois bien chez elle en train de faire
le ménage ou s'occuper de ses enfants
voilà pour Edith Cresson et elle elle
a tous là à la fois de la part de
l'Assemblée nationale de la part de
l'opinion publique des hommes etc et de
son propre parti qui ne la soutenait pas
la comparaison avec la Pompadour dire
qu'elle était une favorite de Mitterrand
que c'est pour ça qu'elle était au
pouvoir c'est
incroyable
misogynie qui pouvait régner dans ces
années-là qui sont des années de gauche
quand même
la gauche franchement ne donne pas non
plus une bonne image d'elle-même à ce
propos je pense qu'il y avait des
progrès tout de même je pense que ça
serait plus possible maintenant et à la
limite voire la première ministre c'est
la deuxième expérience de Première
ministre avec
Elisabeth borne c'est tout autre chose
personne ne fait plus maintenant il me
semble du moins de commentaires sur son
physique sur la manière dont elle est
habillée etc etc et elle-même a l'air
tout à fait décontracté de ce point de
vue là faut pas oublier que cette femme
a fait Polytechnique qu'elle a donc été
aussi dans un milieu très masculin elle
connaît tout ça et là il me semble qu'il
y a un progrès et il y a un progrès qui
me réjouit
[Musique]